I'm Scott o Gallagher gameplay producer
on NBA 2k16 and I'm here to talk to you
about the all-new play now online this
year we wanted head-to-head online games
that matter so an NBA 2k16 we've created
ten different leagues starting with
freshman and moving all the way up to
the greatest of all time your wins and
losses now count towards reaching goals
within your league not just to move up
to the next league but we want to make
sure that you don't drop down to a lower
one this year we wanted head-to-head
online games to matter that's why when
you play in these leagues you'll be
playing with competitors that play your
skill level rising through the ranks
won't be easy so we've added a few tools
to help your journey to the top before
the start of each game will give you a
scouting report on your opponent it
contains a detailed breakdown of your
opponent's strengths weaknesses and
tendencies tired of always playing
against the same team when you play
online and play now online teams have
been broken up into tears if you can
beat teams from higher tiers you get
extra League wins but I've saved my
favorite part for last so as you advance
into higher leagues you'll unlock the
ability to play with some of the
greatest teams in NBA history try NBA
2k16 all new play now online and find
out if you can be the greatest of all
time